foreign
do you know what that stood for
jackass music
[Music]
so Chris came to me and he's like little
bro we really need to start a band
playing behind artists and stuff is cool
but don't you think it'd be cool if like
we played our own I only have a cool how
we just gonna do this all I knew was I
know how to make beats
that really was the beginning of what we
call Jazz
trap is the struggle it's the grind Jazz
open doors for us but Jazz has a horse
in too impossible
cosplay has an origin too the Blues
Blues has an origin slave songs
[Music]
jazz is arguably the most sophisticated
Sonic art form in the world but there's
also this air body where it's like it
comes from black people so it can't be
that sophisticated
they're playing at a very high level
let's put this black music on one of the
highest pedestals we can
[Music]